[Music]
this is a joining of us a shooting and
Hillsdale College the word college means
partnership partnerships always flourish
when they serve a common purpose
Hillsdale College was founded to pursue
four things that form an integrity high
learning character freedom and
the partnership with Hillsdale and USA
shooting is super exciting it's going to
be a very powerful thing for us he's
just having a great partner with like
values that caused it shooting was
something that was passed down
generationally in my family and it
teaches you a lot of things that you use
in life everyday like responsibility
discipline focus and that's really where
you see that the Mel between Hillsdale
and us a shooting come together to
really teach that to the youth to kids
into future generations these are things
that they'll take with them for the rest
of their lives
and at the end of the day they're
creating a legacy not just for the
school but also for the future of the
shooting sports working with us a
shooting we have the opportunity to
introduce more youth to shooting sports
and has ever happened at any college and
we have an ability to do that at a high
level
USA shooting brings in the Olympic ring
which is a pretty powerful statement in
itself it's the best of the best the
most elite athletes being able to work
with youth to give them that opportunity
to pursue an Olympic path is a unique
thing for a school and the great thing
for Hillsdale College and we hope to see
some Olympic athletes coming out of
Hillsdale College right through the
halters Center for a hundred and
seventy-five years Hillsdale College has
been providing the type of education
that makes possible free government and
one of the pillars of that education is
character one of ways to develop
character
at an early age as through shooting
sports Hill so college it has been an
academic informed voice to keep the
Declaration of Independence and the
Constitution the United States in their
sovereign place because it's in our
bones the Olympics are great shooting is
important it should be cultivated and
the responsibility that goes with it
there's our partnership we are proud of
it
[Music]
you